[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 168 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm mark Mandal and this week I'm here
with my colleague John Foust John how
you doing I'm doing great how about you
doing all right
GDC is over so I'm very happy I actually
kind of miss it you miss it yeah see it
was my first one so I had a lot of fun
it was it was pretty awesome it was
pretty awesome so uh yeah this week we
have Ian buck and Kerry brewski joining
us from a video talk to us all about
their new in video t floors in which you
can do it with them on Google cloud
sounds awesome and we will also get into
our question of the week especially
following the new announcement for
stadia so we'll give you a little bit of
more information on that yeah I'll be
really good before you do that why don't
we get stuck into our cool things of the
week we do have a lot of gaming content
but I do want to do what I do pretty
much always which is mention kubernetes
so congratulations to the kubernetes
team they recently released version 1.14
which has some pretty amazing stuff in
it
the thing that I'm particularly excited
about is production level support for
Windows notes I've been waiting for that
for a real long time so I'm very excited
about that
as well as customized integration with
cube CTL and all sorts of other good
things as well so wait for that to come
to your favorite cloud provider near you
shortly I can't wait I'm a big Windows
user following that of course we're
gonna talk about the Stadio release it
is that little thing that amazing new
thing so stadia is a new video game
platform delivering instant access to
your favorite games on any type of
screen that means TV via chromecast on
your laptop that will Chrome your
desktop little chrome tablet or a mobile
phone and we will be launching later
this year in select countries and those
countries include the US Canada UK and
much of Europe I don't know about you
but I actually got my hands on you know
playing stadia at GDC and it was amazing
playing Assassin's Creed Odyssey yeah I
love this just the fact that I don't
need a console I don't need a PC I can
stream the game straight to my computer
although I'm waiting for is this is
really this urgent this experience where
I'm sitting in front of my computer and
I'm like I think I guess I'm gonna play
Assassin's Creed I ought to see you
rather than work on the spreadsheet new
tab go into stadia now I'm playing the
game
we've done yeah it's amazing fantastic
and it also removes the need for you
know those large gaming rigs that
everybody likes to build I have to
personally have to yeah so I imagined
you know just sitting in the airport and
you know being able to play you know
your favorite triple-a titles that you
know potentially making us come to
stadia yeah it's kind of amazing when I
do that now in airports but I like
around the 17 inch gaming laptop the
waste of time don't worry do that
alright so moving on yeah we have a
bunch of gaming stuff here there was a
blog post that came out recently talking
about how Google cloud helped multi-play
power apex legends and their massive
massive massive launch so if anyone's
familiar with the free-to-play shooter
apex legends perk a whole bunch of
Records which is fantastic during the
first eight hours of his debut it
reached up to 1 million unique players
which is pretty amazing that is within
70 the first 72 hours after its initial
launch apex Legends reached 10 million
players and is now reached 50 million
unique players after just one month oh
my god Wow um so this was facilitated by
unities multi play team they helped the
apex legends team basically to
distribute and scale and grow this they
have a particularly unique hybrid
scaling technology to scale the majority
of the demand for apex legends with
Google cloud but also use its network of
bare metal data centers as well yeah
they run up a lot a lot of Google
compute engine instances to make this
happen it's pretty amazing so much
congratulations to FX Legends to the
team at multi play they have done an
excellent job and we're very happy
having them on Google cloud yeah I've
actually played apex legends so just a
bit and it's actually pretty fun so it's
amazing
learning where the team has gone with
that following that we are announcing
that massive Entertainment has selected
Google cloud as the public cloud
provider to host the game servers
globally for the highly anticipated
sequel for the division the division 2
the reason we've been chosen primarily
because Glu clouds secure high speed
fiber network allows for consists of
high performance experiences across
regions so that supports game data and
other core services such as matchmaking
high scores stats inventory and of
course seamless gameplay nice yeah lots
of good game stuff the unsurprisingly
coming out of GDC why don't we go have a
chat with
and carry and hear all about MV deist
he's full I'm very excited to talk to
both Ian and Kerry so super excited to
be in the very fancy offices of Nvidia
today super impressive I actually like
the color scheme a lot dark colors are
definitely my thing green and black very
nice we are joined today by Ian buck GM
and vice-president of accelerated
computing and Carrie Brisky senior
director of accelerated computing
software product management it's a
mouthful how are you doing today great
thank you
excellent welcome yeah thank you thank
you for the res well thank you for
having us second of all thank you for
joining us here on the podcast as well
before we get into all the fun and cool
new Nvidia things do you want to tell us
a little bit about yourselves before we
get stuck in and you want to go first
yeah sure I mean I've been at Nvidia for
I was 18 years now actually started very
early on finishing my PhD at Stanford in
using GPUs for general-purpose computing
and came to Nvidia to actually start
CUDA which was I'll go first
you know the software programming
platform for how people can use GPUs not
just for playing video games but for
actually doing more general-purpose
computing it's been an exciting ride and
today I have a very interesting job of
driving all of our GPS into data centers
around the world yes I'm really big on
the gaming stuff so I'm real excited
about that but really interested in
learning about the computing hi I'm
Carrie Brisky and I've been at Nvidia
for about two and a half years but I've
been a leader and product management for
about 15 years so really trying to focus
on the end-user experience and you know
using our software awesome
and you mentioned CUDA that's a thing do
you want to tell us little bit of the
history of that or like just a broad
overview of like what that is and what
that does and like all those things we
have half an hour it's fine yeah it's a
kind of a fun story you know back in
around 2000 obviously the video game
industry was driving a ton of investment
in pcs and graphics accelerators for
playing video games as a result those
video games were more and more realistic
and more and more programmable a bunch
of academics myself included realize it
that maybe these processors could be
used for something other than playing
quake and Doom and evening
which of course we always find so we
started looking at these thrusters and
it turns out Bait were like doubling in
performance like how many floating-point
operations they could do literally every
year and repeatedly year over year and
there were pretty hard to programmers
from a general perspective using
graphics API so that Coppage and DX so I
started a project early on at Stanford
called Brooke which was to explore how
can we program these things in a more
general-purpose way in a way that
exploited there's our natural ability to
double in performance to defy Moore's
law but be usable by a general
programming audience in C and other
languages that was very successful
project open sourced it got it out there
I mean over ten thousand users and then
Jensen our CEO invited me to come to
Nvidia and do it for real so we started
CUDA back in 2004 learned all those
lessons of how to do parallel
programming kind of for the masses on a
different kind of accelerator massively
parallel one GPU and took it off from
there at Washington in 2006 and
instantly became very successful in
high-performance computing in
supercomputing and today in AI also on
behalf of many millions of gamers around
the world thank you and I'm really
excited to see like the big shift
towards general computing and processing
so we're excited what makes it so
exciting is that it's so accessible you
know anyone can you know go to Fry's by
laptop with the GPU and AG and get
access to the platform download it for
free and even on their gaming PC you
know try it out and figure out what they
could do we're all about these stories
of PhD students who graduate in
Streetman undergrads you know blowing
away their peers or professors or
classmates and kind of stuff they can do
with GPUs that it was never even
imaginable when we started this whole
thing
yeah Kari I think probably you have a
good perspective on like where do you
see cooter and like the things that
people are doing GPUs like what are the
applications people are doing with that
right now
yeah like like Ian said there's a
variety of applications but I would
focus on the AI what's kind of exciting
and happening is the easy thing to say
is everywhere but if I were to sort of
break down AI applications and what our
customers are doing I sort of bucket
them into three groups and that's like
computer vision speech and audio and
then machine comprehension NLP and so
you can even
those down into you know deeper lower
buckets of different types of neural
networks which we call the Cambrian
explosion because you know almost every
task under these buckets is a you know
can be applied with the neural network
it's awesome to see things evolve over
time it all started with that first
Alex net you know Alex Kresge a guy up
in Canada he was working on this thing
which had been totally forgotten about
deep neural networks as a researcher
working with Hinton and you know heard
about this thing called CUDA heard about
this stuff math that we were doing with
HPC and realized it was the same math
that he was doing in his research in AI
which that back then was still the you
know the AI winter he wrote the first
accelerated framework for AI and
invented Alex now that's why it's called
alex nets and he did a bunch of gaming
GPUs to GTX 570s way back in I guess was
2012 it all took off from there today I
think we have a massive collection of
different kinds of neural networks
different applications of AI and that's
what makes it so fun this whole field is
constantly reinventing itself or
something it's funny he said way back in
2012 it's actually you know Alex Nets
consider like a toy now considering the
new neural networks which are really
deep and very complex I actually still
have my GTX 680 I don't think oh yeah
it's somewhere at collecting dust I'll
probably end up using Alex and I can see
if I can mess around do some things yeah
we've we've made things a little faster
since that those first GPUs again we're
designed for HPC computing use cases and
of course video games but since then
we've been constantly reinventing our
GPU in fact we pump through and create
new architectures new software stacks
literally every year because that's how
fast things are changing in this world
speaking of new things I know you'll
introduce something new recently maybe
something cool suppose yeah we just came
out of our GDC conference and which is
our main developer conference which we
invite the world to come and we share
some of the things that we've been
working on they share the stuff that
they'd be doing on our platform which is
really exciting we've been improving our
AI performance for sure there's two
parts of AI there's the training part
where we're teaching neural networks to
learn new things one of the things that
we've been doing is actually making that
faster and easier
get the peak performance out of our GPUs
and particularly in frameworks like
tensorflow courtesy of you guys Google
which we work very closely with getting
access to the performance that are
available in our latest GPU course
called tensor core which is a mixed
precision core that can do things in
64-bit floating-point 32-bit
floating-point 16-bit even 8-bit because
AI can take advantage of all those
different Precision's and the different
layers of performance the new thing we
announced with tensor flow amp which is
our NVIDIA amp acceleration into the
tensor flow framework to take advantage
of that mixed precision automatically
for users it will automatically pick the
right precision for the right layers of
the neural network and maximize
performance or seeing huge speed ups
this is like 2/3 X even about for AI
training and it's literally like a 1 to
2 line change in your tense flow script
the goal was to give like a great
experience out of the box so the deep
learning practitioner doesn't have to
change the hardware they don't have to
change the hyper parameters working in
the framework that you feel most
comfortable with which for a lot of
people is tensor flow we also have some
solutions for PI torch and MX node as
well but amp stands for automatic mix
precision which is that training
technique for being able to feed your
input on FB 16 and accumulate FP 32
which turns out is really important for
keeping the accuracy of your gradients
through training you said a bunch of
words there some of them I might even
know what they are can you break that
down a little further yeah I think like
if I have like three takeaways that I
want you to take away for the amp
automatic mix precision is that you only
have to change two lines of code and
things just go way faster so if you're a
deep learning practitioner you've
training any neural networks and maybe
it takes like a day to train you can now
do it in half a day who isn't you can
run double the experiments right out of
the box without doing anything different
that's kind of cool and then there's no
accuracy versus speed trade-off from
experts isn't training I want to be
pretty clear about that cuz you say
lower precision and yeah you're training
in less bits ft 16s of FB 32 but you're
not losing accuracy and so I want to be
very clear about that and have people
understand that and that's the third
takeaway is that automatic mix precision
training is general purpose across a
variety of different applications
yeah there's a lot of talk about
precision and using all sorts of
different kind of numerical formats and
and math it's really hard to get the
peak performance and not do any
compromises we've made that easier by
putting all that smarts
all that intelligent all those numerix
and complex equations and loss functions
more words into a box for you yep and
that was one of the big engagements and
talking with our customers is that they
want to get the best performance but
they're not the ninja data scientists
right they just want to get the best
performance out of the cheap use of the
buying and we've made it all easier with
amp and we're excited about it
so GCP and NVIDIA what kind of hardware
with launching together
gzb has been a great partner you guys
always want to put the best GPUs in the
cloud if we track customers and if you
have since the days of kepler which has
been fantastic we now have our Volta
v100 GPUs in the cloud with tensor core
amp is specifically designed to run
those lightning fast and then just last
year we also announced our T 4 GPUs with
GCP this is a little bit different kind
of GPU is designed for inference the
other side of AI one is training
teaching a neural network how to
recognize things speech the words I'm
saying what's inside a managed that's
the learning part then there's a
deployment part the scale out the
running of the services the deployment
of AI in the past that used to run on
you know whatever CPUs you had and
typically there was a compromise you
picked a small neural network or maybe
you couldn't do everything the new AI
that's coming out now are incredibly
intelligent very powerful and precise
yeah they're also very big lots of
floating-point operations and this has
to be real time you know it's got to
recognize my speech as fast as I'm
talking right now
which is probably too fast that's why
people are now moving inference to
acceleration so you guys were the first
actually to launch t4 in the cloud
congratulations and we've been working
together to make inference even faster
jointly with with customers yeah and
just for the audience out there
inference is taking that terrain model
and using it for predictions I think a
lot of people use the term predictions
and we use the term inference yeah what
kind of speed increases are we talking
about here what is magnitude I mean some
stuff it was not possible before
processing audio
doing intelligent decision-making if I
ask a question I want to have an
intelligent answer back not just what
wikipedia says or actually be able to
produce speech I don't think people
realize that when could be
back to you you men notice the last few
years it's gotten really good it's
really good at sounding like a human
that's actually because of a new neural
network technology called wave nets
wave nets actually taken basically a
robotic sounding voice and I'll put a
nice sounding voice like you and I oh I
think I've actually heard of that it's
like you read off roughly around like
200 lines and it starts to imitate your
own voice so you can read back to you
and this is exactly how text-to-speech
services work and they have a lot of
applications not just the you know home
speaker device but even in businesses
and call centers and how we talk to
computers through automation systems if
they sound natural people want to engage
with them I think goes right to the
bottom line of an engagement score at a
Sat score for business so this is one of
the new hot areas in AI it's one of the
big demand generators for our GPUs
because you just can't run wave nets on
legacy platforms they're too big and too
complicated and they're too important
not to get right for those kinds of
services yeah yes exactly like what kind
of speed ups and it does depend on the
model and we call it finding your
quality of service so if you have you
know these ensemble models or an output
of one model feeds into the input of
another model and they all have to be
done in like this enormous cosmic power
an itty-bitty living space of latency
and so if you add all that latency up it
has to have that delightful end-user
experience so if you speak into a search
query and then it text-to-speech back to
you it's intha sizing speech back to you
that all has to happen and nice little
tiny tiny window yeah so latency matters
if I'm gonna ask a question I can't wait
a second for an answer to come back I
just won't use this service I won't use
it on my phone in consumer so you have
to deliver responses you know in a tenth
of a second otherwise you know after
that the enjoyment score starts to fall
off and people stop using it so we are
seeing throughputs and speed ups in the
you know 10 to 100 X by moving on to
GPUs especially for some of the new
models like wave nets for natural
language processing like the new model
called Bert what is this come with great
names I encourage anyone listening is
actually working on the science and
Ernie
we need a Ernie
so burt stands for carry can you do it
bi-directional encoder representations
in transformers meets what is that
burt is the new neural network that's
used to understand language okay
language being a what we call natural
language processing you give it a
webpage please summarize that web page
understanding text and contents and
languages as I'm speaking understanding
what I mean and what's the sentiment and
summarize it this is very important for
things like advertising for search I
need to know you know is this tweet a
good tweet a bad tweet who should I
share it with is it positive toward
so-and-so or negative it's the new model
that has become up it's been talked
about as the grand unifying natural
language processing model that can
understand all language they have many
different models for different use cases
this is the latest one it's a great
multitasker it's huge it's gigantic but
it's very intelligent very powerful it's
being used already in production today
with certain companies for doing things
like sentiment analysis content
filtering is this a safe thing to share
not a safe thing to share a very
important part of AI today and one of
the driving forces for moving AI to GPUs
our listeners obviously can't see me but
I have like this huge grin on my face
it's so many light bulbs are going off
in my mind right now for future projects
and this sounds completely awesome so
curious availability for the t4 it's
available today so people can rent it
right now from GCP see if you're an
on-prem customer you get the also
available on servers we were available
everywhere you know our mission is to
make our technology available through
every channel the cloud is great time to
market especially GCP so we're excited
that you guys are leaning in and getting
our latest technology out there we also
make our software available so we do a
huge amount of work and people don't
always understand this to accelerate the
frameworks the eye frameworks like
tensor flow or the rest of the inference
software stacks that users of the cloud
can very quickly deploy these models or
build services on top of it we publish
optimized framework containers about
every month now across the board
tensorflow but also pi torch and MX and
the other guys we also publish a bunch
of our inference software which care can
explain more to allow customers to just
not have to
build AI from scratch but start from
standard building blocks and all that
runs on GCP right of the gate yeah I
guess I mean you said that t4 has a
little bit of everything for everyone
the FB 64 it's got enough 8:32 you get
FB 16 you get and date but our software
is built in so that you can actually
like flip a switch and sort of exploit
these features like tensor cores inside
the hardware but I want to say that FP
16 is a great format for inference I've
mentioned earlier that we have this
mixed precision for training but you
don't actually have to have that for
inference either you can literally just
flip a switch and know that you'll get
the same sort of accuracy within state
there's a little bit more consideration
that has to be taken in both with your
training and quantization of these
weights and activations but you do get
benefits of memory space and power
limitations when you actually take it to
a sort of this reduced precision and we
offer a software that can do that for
you and one thing that we did is this
software framework called tensor RT and
we've integrated it into tensorflow
there's a lot of tensors you had GCC
where GCP it's all fine exactly so what
we've done is we've taken that software
that takes the best advantage of
optimizations and put it right in to
where people do most of their work which
is tensorflow that we push all this
software on the web free to download as
containers they can pull from the I
assume Lake docker containers and it's
all standard it's all in dr. Tanner's in
fact we also have examples of all the
models so they don't need to download
separate model from everywhere it's all
captured in the containers as a
straight-up building block to fire up
and run and create a service built on
these things so if you want the latest
burke that's been optimized for GPUs or
the latest resident 50 or whatever have
you you know feel free to comfort in
video comm there on it's actually n GC
video comm you can download all those
bits and pieces they all are qualified
and run on GC P we even have some HPC
stuff on there there's some based CUDA
containers if you want to actually get
your hands dirty and program GPUs
directly all that software is freely
available and maintained and ready to
run on GC peace cloud again the URL is
GC I'll put a link in the show notes
don't make it make that easy same URLs
out loud is complicated and hot yes
you know we're seeing that shift from
on-prem the cloud conversation having
all sorts of places not just obviously
in the AI world but also on the
traditional computing space the
high-performance computing guys that
people doing you know simulations for
drug discovery or understanding
astrophysics and how galaxies and stars
we do a lot of that work - and actually
all that can be done also in on the same
GPUs in the cloud so you know some of
the research community the higher ed
guys people doing science and discovery
can take advantage of these GPUs as well
that's awesome that's interesting now
I'm actually kind of curious you brought
the on Prem coat discussion in which is
always interesting where do you see
people using the cloud versus on Prem
and like the trade-offs Darrien and like
what helps people make those sort of
decisions for using GPUs and servers
essentially you know a lot of this new
AI technology is being invented in the
cloud that's what makes it so exciting
and what I love about the cloud is the
accessibility you just get and get
access right away and to try it to use
it it's a you know a few bucks an hour
or even cents an hour to get access to a
GPU and start using GPS for AI or CUDA
or whatever you don't have to go through
the IT we do see trade-offs at the
larger scale business decisions what
makes sense to keep on Prem versus
pushing the cloud some of that's
economics for sure but others you know
security or whether that they just want
to maintain that as their own Enclave
that they can control because this is
really important for their business from
our standpoint we're agnostic my job is
to make our technology available through
all the channels and I certainly like
working with GCP because I know how
aggressive you guys are and bring the
latest technology to the cloud one of
the big deals for on Prem versus cloud
and with some of the work that we've
done is with the kubernetes community so
making sure that GPUs are sort of
first-class citizens and this one was
completely vanilla to the work that
you're doing so you can have your
kubernetes cluster deployment on prem
and then you can sort of burst to the
cloud with the same settings we've done
a lot of work there with you know being
able to make sure that it's pumping out
metrics of like GPU utilization power
metrics and you know how are you
that system administrator like what is
the health of my system and how did GPUs
fit into that we want to make it as
vanilla as possible we don't want GPUs
to be view it just like this unique and
beautiful
course they're lovely don't get them
wrong I did want to bring up a little
bit the inference server you kind of
like these three basic blocks when
you're sort of working through AI
deployments you have the pre-processing
of the data you have the training and
then maybe if you're really expert you
have this optimization and then
deployment and I hate to use something
as mundane as DevOps or something as
exciting as AI but that's kind of what
it is and I think some people who might
get scared about you know where do I
begin with AI model development you just
kind of take that same practice and
approach to it and we have tools that
every step along the way for every
person whether you are data or
pre-processing if you're deep learning
data scientists and researcher if you're
the software developer who's trying to
integrate the model into that
application and then the system
administrator who's trying to you know
take care of all the stuff and keep the
health of their yeah so you can see
we're pretty active at all layers of
that software stack not just the cutting
edge of the actual development of new AI
usage but all the way down the system
management and monitoring and like Kara
said you know all the excitement around
kubernetes are definitely in there
working very closely with that community
to make sure that it's all GPU ready the
other area that's hot right now is the
traditional machine learning we talk a
lot about AI but you know a lot of that
math it's reinvigorating data science
you know there's a lot of algorithms out
there that actually are well proven and
very successful for doing predictive
analytics that are you know with more
traditional linear regressions k-means
clustering gradient boosted decision
trees we've also started to accelerate
those workloads it's the similar kind of
math and operations that were doing
before we've integrated with Google on
some of your cloud ml pipeline workflows
to accelerate some of the algorithms
before deploying for traditional
predictive analytics particularly
gradient boosted entries rxg boost comes
up a lot in forecasting you want to know
when I'm gonna go out of stock of
bananas and I need [ __ ] more bananas
there's point-of-sale data for every
retail store all around the world and
data scientists are drowning in data
they just lack the compute to actually
make those kinds of predictions and
often in the time windows that matter
which can be literally just hours so
we're starting to see much more
acceleration of traditional machine
learning
we have a software stack called Rapids
which is bringing some of those
algorithms collection of algorithms and
GPU of finding them making them
available to people to integrate into
their predictive analytics platforms
particularly we've been working with
Google on accelerating those as well and
that's some of the stuff that we've been
talking about here at GTCC
and it's exciting to see not just deep
learning but all of the machine learning
recognize the opportunity that GPS can
bring to accelerating all those kinds of
predictive workloads where would
developers data scientists anybody who
wants to use these interesting things go
to get started
everywhere so like Ian said earlier the
easiest places and GCM video comm we
have a lot of containers we have
examples we have models and scripts of
you know exactly the recipes that we
have applied to get the best performance
to the state-of-the-art accuracy for all
of these models like II and said before
we work really hard to put this into
open source software as much as possible
so like if you're using a GCP VM you
know we actually stay in contact with
the VM team to make sure that they're
getting the latest optimizations that
we've contributed to tensorflow so that
they're working perfectly on our latest
GPUs we've also been you know providing
educational services as well so our GGC
conference we host many hackathons we've
host many tutorials we have our own deep
Learning Institute which we call DL I
frequently customers come to us and they
want to just learn about AI so we have a
program where anyone can come and sign
up and we'll run the deep Learning
Institute at their company we'll show
them how to use lists the ins will show
them how to configure their GPUs to get
them started they'll actually train a
neural network go use it and by doing
sort of the canonical use case of a toy
use case they can then turn around and
go back with their companies and then go
from being just a DevOps percenters to
traditional data scientists to being an
AI expert and figure out how to apply
these things to their business use cases
we're very active in that community
people obviously working with many
customers that want to get started on
GPUs I want to get started in AI just
don't know how you know we see it our
mission to help educate and help and I
know we said it earlier but the product
manager me really cares about the end
user in their persona and what they're
trying to do with their job and so if
your system administrator you can feel
good about our contributions to Cooper
net
and check out our data center GP
management utilities again all of this
is on NGC daughter video comm if you're
a deep learning practitioner definitely
check out amp when again that's in the
framework that you use most to take
advantage of mix precision training
we've also made available cupola
pipelines so examples directly into the
cue flow pipeline repository across a
variety of applications were entering
one for medical Imogene we're entering
one for intelligent video analytics for
transfer learning and then we're also
doing sort of like the hello world with
ResNet 50 and deploying that on an
inference server with cue pipelines and
new kubernetes and then if you're the
software developer who really doesn't
know anything about deep learning models
you just know that you have to kind of
put it into your software application to
get this you know say yeah I'm using AI
definitely check our inference server
that's also open source software one of
my favorite questions to ask what's been
the most interesting or potentially
weird or wacky thing that you've seen
people do with AI or Nvidia chips what's
kind of wacky about it you know one
thing that's gotten a lot of notice
lately is the celebrity face synthesis
it's kind of a lot of press and
attention and I think there is even a
site that you can click on try and guess
like which face is real that's been kind
of the neat one lately I've seen my face
plastered on a few people which is very
interesting there all sorts of
applications of AI that I've seen I
think some of the coolest ones aren't
actually in agriculture these people
don't think about that much but you know
there's a I believe there's a cow with a
Fitbit on it and they're trying to
figure out the engine steps in yeah try
to figure out the health of cows and
proved milk output I understand when
cows are sick using AI to understand you
know herds very cool stuff
there's actually a interesting work in
strawberry picking I didn't know this
but apparently a strawberry fields need
to be picked every three days so it's
not like that crop you grow and pick it
like you have to constantly be picking
it and it's an area that it's actually
very labor intensive and obviously it's
hard to find all this farm labor that
can constantly come and pick it for
three days so there's all these cool
stuff in robotics right now there's a
strawberry picker that's being developed
with GPUs that has a little articulating
arm and a camera it's a head of it's
actually really hard problem you got to
figure out and do segment analysis which
pixels are which strawberries even if
they
and what's the ideal place to grab the
stand and cut it you never want to
actually touch the strawberry because
that would actually you know potentially
transfer your funguses or molds and that
kinda stuff strawberries and you got
every three days so there's some really
cool stuff having in robotics and I'm
that I think is some of the next
generation and stuff that we're going to
start seeing coming out of AI just very
convincing very compelling very
interesting robotics applications that
are gonna make our lives a lot easier
being a gamer I do happen to have RTX
2080 just curious to see if we can see
that same technology that is being
introduced in RTX within the GPUs that
are gonna be in datacenters yeah one
thing we've always done is we made our
technology available on all of our GPUs
and that's me so successful is the fact
that anyone can get access to the latest
in video tech even if their gamer
because many of the people actually
inventing the next generation stuff
whether it be you know science or AI
they're probably gamers too so uh so
with twenty r-tx actually all the tents
our core capabilities are there
available we're already starting to put
into games so in fact there's work being
done for final frame rendering so at the
very end of a frame of your rendering of
the frame of a game we actually can
apply AI to it to improve its visual
quality we actually spent a lot of work
training the neural network to improve
the image quality we actually render it
in much higher resolution and then down
scale and teach in AI had to do
automatic color correction to eliminate
jaggies to do anti-aliasing using AI on
every frame yeah that's like millions of
pixels 60 times a second we actually do
a full neural network on every one of
those pixels to actually improve it to
do a final pass for a improvement on
your GPU it's a really hard thing I mean
that's real real time imagine that's why
I think AI is gonna affect an impact and
improve every one of the applications of
GPUs in every industry not just
agriculture but gaming you know
automation robotics the cloud super
exciting vision we are running out of
time just a little bit but before we go
is there anything that you want to make
sure that these listeners hear about or
you want to plug any events you're gonna
be at or any new content that's been
delivered recently that you want to make
sure people are aware of yeah so I think
a lot of our biggest event has already
passed but
you can always visit our booth or you
know come see us when we're at all the
top AR conferences
some examples are ICML I CLR cvpr
there's a lot of acronyms here but your
name but if you know them they're
speaking to you me
we're also attending more of the
obviously DevOps and cloud conferences
we'll be at Google cloud next and will
be a cube con and other places so reach
out feel free to contact Nvidia again
we're working on all of the stacks and
the applications so please don't
hesitate well that's gonna wrap it up
for us we will really really enjoy this
light bulbs are still going off once
again I would like to thank you guys for
joining us on the GC podcast yeah thank
you thank you bye thanks again to Ian
and Kerry for joining us on the podcast
and telling us all the amazing things
that are happening with the NVIDIA T
fours but also thank you so much to the
nvidia team for hosting us at the nvidia
office it is a gorgeous office if you
ever get down that way it is super
amazing and I am a big fan of dark
tinted glass so it is amazing oh yes so
thanks so much for that so before we
wrap up question of the week I know
you've been digging into this a little
bit John so just a bit if people are
interested in stadia and they want to
learn more
either as a potential consumer or a
potential developer where can those
people go so the best place to go would
be stadia dev it's the new landing page
for stadium there you can find all the
general information that you need and if
you would like to sign up for developer
access the best place to go is stadia
dev slash apply whoa John or are you
gonna be what are you doing what's going
on you do anything special maybe a
couple special things I'm gonna be a
cloud next in a couple of weeks I will
also be AE CGC
mid-april and I will also be at vector
2019 which will be very amazing
I have also jumped on board to be at i/o
this year so this would be great because
it's my first I oh no fun and I will
potentially be at unite Shanghai which
would be a great experience
Oh congratulations on working out what
you're doing post i/o yeah so yeah I
will be at Club next as well I will be
hanging out at the GCP Park house booth
so definitely if people are gonna be at
next come by the GC pub house booth
myself will be there drum will be there
well variety of hosts that we have will
be there Gabby will be there etc so
definitely come by we'll be doing some
recording on the show floor and doing
live episodes all the usual good stuff I
will also be at risk roast game
conference just like John and then I'll
also be at i/o as well I was pretty
exciting will tell you more about that
as we get a bit closer yeah fantastic
John thanks so much for joining me yet
again on the podcast this week it's
always a pleasure wonderful and thank
you all for listening and we'll see you
all next week
[Music]
thanks again to in and Kerry for joining
us and also allowing us to have a
wonderful visit at the advendio Olivia
Nvidia and VIN VIN diem Vidya